it does look like at least some
Republican senators are gonna do the
right thing and they're going to vote to
have key witnesses like John Bolton
testify in the Senate impeachment trial
you'll remember we talked about it
earlier earlier already in the context
of the propaganda war that is being
waged at the start of Donald Trump's
Senate impeachment trial Republicans
were able to get an absolutely
ridiculous decision to talk about
subpoenaing witnesses and documents and
audio-visual records after both sides
have had their 24 hours to present their
cases and possibly even after eat there
have been 16 hours of questions from
senators this makes no sense knowing
which documents will be introduced
knowing which witnesses will testify
would be hugely important to structuring
your case as would be done in any other
kind of trial but this is what
Republicans were able to pull off good
for them I guess although it's
completely ridiculous so soon this is
going to become the subject in the
Senate we know that you need only a
simple majority to a subpoena witnesses
meaning the 45 Democrats the two
independent senators who caucus with
Democrats that's 47 and for Republicans
it seems that we have a couple of
Republicans that are going in the
direction of at least voting to subpoena
john bolton to testify one of those
individuals is Utah Republican Senator
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney spoke to
reporters and said he has yet to decide
but he does seem to be leaning in that
direction it's increasingly apparent
that it would be important to hear from
John Bolton
I of course will make a final decision
on witnesses after we've heard from not
only the prosecution but also the
defense but I think at this stage it's
pretty fair to say that John Bolton has
a relevant testimony I think it's
increasingly likely that other
Republicans will will join those of us
who think we should hear from John
Bolton this came right after the New
York Times published those excerpts from
John Bolton's upcoming book his
manuscript of the book where Bolton
destroys every single talking point in
the defense of Donald Trump on the
Ukraine issue John Bolton very plainly
and clearly saying in his upcoming book
Trump told him withhold the military aid
to Ukraine
until they smear Joe Biden publicly this
testimony would be devastating to the
Republican narrative and to Donald
Trump's narrative and we're going to
talk more about what that testimony
might do in a little bit we also heard
from senator Susan Collins Susan Collins
Republican senator from Maine she often
is very concerned about something but
then ends up voting with Republicans she
put out a statement where she said from
the beginning I've said that in fairness
to both parties the decision on whether
or not to call witnesses should be made
after both the house managers and the
president's attorneys have had the
opportunity to present their cases she's
wrong about that the decision should be
made earlier but okay this is her
position going on to say I've always
said that I was likely to vote to call
witnesses just as I did in the 1999
Clinton trial the reports about John
Bolton's book strengthen the case for
witnesses and have prompted a number of
conversations among my colleagues so
that's potentially two Republicans who
will join the Democrats and independents
that would make 49 votes you still need
two more to get to the 51 that are
needed but increasingly there are
rumblings that there will be for at
least four Republicans who vote to
subpoena john bolton now even if john
bolton shows up you aren't going to get
a conviction of donald trump but that's
not relevant now we knew that going in
and exposing what john bolton has to say
to the widest possible audience
once again confirming the brazen nature
of donald trump's lies would be a very
good thing there's always a risk that
Republican senators will say I lean
towards testifying or whatever and then
they don't actually vote for it in the
end Susan Collins has done that many
times go back to the Cavanaugh hearings
until they actually vote I will assume
nothing of them but it looks like this
may actually become a reality
John Bolton's testimony Romney
politically would suffer no consequences
from his vote by the way Mitt Romney
could get reelected indefinitely in Utah
as long as he wants no matter what he
does as many of you know Utah has a
large Mormon population Romney is Mormon
Utah's also very conservative Mitt
Romney has that seat for essentially as
long as he wants it hopefully he's not
just saying he'd consider voting that
way and
actually we'll we've we've been
disillusioned before we've seen Mitt
Romney and Susan Collins sometimes Lisa
Murkowski they pretend to have a spine
they pretend to have morals they say
they're very worried and then they just
vote with Republicans
so we'll believe it if and when we see
it it will do nothing to secure votes
for the conviction of Donald Trump from
Republicans remember that I just don't
trust them and anything that depends on
a few Republicans acting appropriately
we've learned over the last twenty years
it's just not something we can count on
in American politics but let's now get
to the effect of the Bolton testimony
because Republicans are panicking about
what that possible testimony could mean
and could cause so let's talk about that
next do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that there are just not
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire non-fiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I've
just finished listening to upheaval by
Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a tremendous
author whose work I've previously
recommended excellent book looking at
some of modern history's biggest
national crises to figure out how
different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blinka stay
of books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink as comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you